Let's begin by going over how we can apply animations to metahumans with and without
sequencer.
Then we will take a look at the bodyik retargetor assets and facial animation tools that are
already set up to work with metahumans.
We previously saw how we can apply existing body and facial animations to our metahumans
in sequencer.
Once added to a level sequence, we delete the default control rigs, then use the plus
sign on either the face or body component to add an animation track.
There may be cases where you want to quickly visualize a body or face animation without
opening up a level sequence.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine for a moment and see how we can apply an animation to a
metahuman without using sequencer.
In Unreal Engine, with our metahuman selected in the level, if we go to the details panel,
we can select if we want to apply an animation to the body or face component by simply selecting
that component.
Right below in the animation setting, we can change the animation mode from use animation
blueprint to use animation asset.
And over here, we can apply an animation sequence to the body.
I will search for mh body animation and select it.
To see the animation play from this camera position, we can go up here to the play and
editor options and select simulate.
Our animation will start to play in the viewport.
And this will allow us to quickly visualize a body animation on our metahuman without
using sequencer.
I'm going to press stop and select the metahuman again and go back to the body component and
I will clear the animation asset from here.
And then reset the animation mode back to use animation blueprint.
Now let's review the steps we just covered before moving on.
We can apply animation sequences to either the body or face component by changing the
animation mode to use animation asset.
With this setting, we can select any animation we want to apply to a metahuman.
Then we can change the play and editor setting to simulate and view the animation in the
viewport without having to open up sequencer.
Just remember when you are done to clear the animation sequence and reset the animation
mode.
Now let's return to Unreal Engine and take a look at the body ik retargetor assets we
can use with metahumans.
In Unreal Engine, to locate the ik retargetor assets, inside of the metahumans folder, go
to the common folder, then to the other common folder, then inside of the animation folder
is the retargeting folder.
Here we will find retargeting assets.
Over here we have an ikrig asset for each of the metahuman body proportions that we
have brought into this project.
If I open this up, we can see on the right that all of the joints have been mapped out
as chains.
So for example, spine 1 to spine 5 makes up the spine chain.
Now let's go back and open up the ik retargetor asset.
Inside of here we have a source and a target.
Our source has the existing animation curves we want to transfer to our character which
is the target.
On the bottom right we can see the animation curves are transferred from the source to
the target by matching the bone chains.
We can do a lot more things with the ikrig and retargetor assets.
Let's go back and look for the animation blueprint retargetor asset and then open this
up.
In the animation graph, if we select the retarget post from mesh node, in the details panel
we can see the ikretargetor asset is assigned.
This allows us to stream in live motion capture data and transfer source data to our target
while using the ikretargetor tools to make adjustments in real time.
Let's do a quick review before we move on.
Animations can be animated using real time or offline animation retargeting workflows.
Retargeting involves transferring animation curves from one skeleton to another.
Unreal Engine 5 uses ikrigs and ikretargetor setups which involve mapping out joints to
bone chains and then transferring animation curves from the source to a target by matching
the bone chains.
Meta humans are also set up to work with facial animation tools.
Facial animation tools that meta humans can be used with include LiveLink face, Meta
Human Animator and Audio Driven Animation.
LiveLink face is a real time facial animation tool allowing you to bring your meta human
to life instantly in Unreal Engine and uses up to 52 ARKit control curves.
Meta Human Animator is an offline facial animation tool using over 200 control curves
to produce high quality facial animation data by utilizing depth footage from an iPhone
or vertical stereo HMC.
Audio driven animation allows you to process audio in order to produce realistic facial
animations and all of these tools are available to use for free with your Epic Games account.
It is worth mentioning that because Meta humans use a shared skeleton for the body and for
the face you can easily transfer animations from one project to another or from older
engine versions to new ones.
Let's jump into Unreal Engine and take a look at this process.
In the source files folder of this course there is a body animation sequence UAssetFile.
If you wish to transfer Meta Human Animation Sequences from one project to another or from
older engine versions to newer ones, in File Explorer copy the UAssetFile you wish to transfer.
Then select a folder you wish to add it to by right clicking on that folder and selecting
Show in Explorer.
Then paste it in the desired File Explorer folder of your Unreal Engine project.
The animation sequence asset will appear in your project.
Now let's review the steps we just completed.
We have just seen how we can easily add Meta Human Animation Sequence UAssetFiles to Unreal
Engine projects.
Simply copy the animation sequence UAssetFile from File Explorer then inside of your Unreal
Engine project select any folder you wish to add it to and right click on that folder
and select Show in Explorer.
Then paste the UAssetFile into the File Explorer folder of your Unreal Engine project.
Since there have been changes to the Meta Human Skeletons in newer versions of Unreal
Engine you may be prompted to assign this newly added animation sequence to the face
archetype for facial animations and the Meta Human Base Skeleton for the body animations.
Now that we have touched on some of the ways we can apply animations to Meta Humans let's
move on to the next section of this course where we explore the optimized Meta Humans
that we can download from Quixel Bridge.